america is known for three things
baseball
apple pie and not spending money on
social services
we're one of the richest nations in the
world but we don't have a lot of cool
things other developed countries have
like
the ability to go to the dentist without
taking on a loan
but how did we get here let's find out
in a segment called
how did we get here
it seems like these days no one can
agree on anything
is climate change real should we double
mask does sugar belong on grits
well apparently all this division is
caused by this thing called
economic anxiety i'm sure you've heard
of it it's a euphemism that describes a
whole set of confusing beliefs
people with economic anxiety love small
government but
are happy to spend billions on prisons
or a border wall
they hate regulations but they love to
regulate women's bodies
the myth of economic anxiety has been
around since slavery
because america loves a euphemism that's
why we call it climate change instead of
everybody gonna drown if y'all stop
playing it's why we call woody allen a
director
instead of an alleged child molester who
is also
very ugly but economic anxiety and all
the things it's a euphemism for
are caused by a concept called the
zero-sum fallacy
that's the belief that one person's gain
means another person's loss
think of america as a pie this should be
an easy analogy to follow because
at any given moment 90 percent of
americans are eating pie
basically economically anxious people
think that when anyone else gets a piece
of pie
there must be less pie to go around they
believe that
if everyone gets health care insurance
premiums will rise or
if we raise minimum wages companies will
lay off workers or
if we spend more money on public
education then the police won't have
money for bear essentials like this
now to me the benefits of spending money
on social services is clear
it's obvious we should be doing it just
like it's obvious we should all watch
bridgerton alone when our husband isn't
home
but many americans don't feel that way
they get nervous about spending money on
services that benefit
all americans but that wasn't always the
case
according to a recent new york times
article in 1960
70 of white americans believe that
the government ought to guarantee a job
for anyone who wants one and ensure
a minimum standard of living for
everyone in the country
by 1964 that number had dropped to just
35 percent
now what could have happened between
1960 and 1964 to change the way white
people felt
what could that have been can you guys
think of anything
that's right when white americans
thought the social safety net was for
them they were all for it but
when it started to look like black
americans might also get a piece of that
pie
they changed their mind fortunately very
few economic systems are modeled after
desserts
in fact it's the opposite you get more
pie when you share more pie
take minimum wage for example studies
show that companies that pay a living
wage
actually make more money and then the
people making a living wage
boost the economy by spending money on
things like food
and clothes and whatever this is
if everyone had health care hospitals
wouldn't have to overcharge people
to make up for patients who don't have
health care the surest way to lower
costs is to insure
more people it's also the surest way to
stop people from googling
can i take my own appendix out at home
do you
ever wonder why there's a lot less crime
in rich neighborhoods
it's because crime is caused by poverty
poor education and lack of resources
so if we spend more money on education
mental health services and job training
crime will go down now where will we get
all this extra money from
well since we already know that
investing in these things lowers crime
how about using some of the big pile of
money sitting in police funding
if only there was a name for this
economic concept
oh well more education and job training
means
more people making a living wage which
means
more tax revenue which means more pie
which is great because as we've already
established americans
love pie now people with economic
anxiety will call these things
government handouts but they're not
worried about the government handing
money out
they're worried about who the government
is handing money to
they only want it to go to certain
people well guess what
that's all of our money it comes from
the taxes we
all pay and we all deserve a piece of
that pie
no matter your race gender sexuality or
creed even if your creed is apollo
in fact the only way we will ever get
rid of economic anxiety is if we stop
hoarding so much damn pie unless of
course
economic anxiety was just racism all
along
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
[Applause]
you